pues la situación es desesperadas sobre
todo para esas personas que han decidido
que no han podido marcharse de las
regiones afectadas sobre todo una
provincia la más De nada es la provincia
de tejatay donde algunas de las personas
que se fueron Durante los primeros días
y semanas después del terremoto que han
vuelto después cuentan que la situación
en lo que antes eran las ciudades de
esas regiones completamente desesperada
con edificios siendo derruidos por las
autoridades con una situación de
inseguridad muy grande por las noches
Porque mucha gente de esas provincias no
tenía cuentas bancadas y las tenía ahí
no es donde guardaba sus ahorros sino
que lo hacían en cuestión de dólares
euros o incluso oro debajo de sus
colchones o escondidos en casa esta
gente tuvo que abandonar el domingo de
la madrugada del lunes de hace justo un
mes
sus casas sin nada y muchos cuentan que
al entrar en sus viviendas después lo
han perdido absolutamente a todo este
terremoto que ha causado como
explicabais muy bien más de 50.000
personas fallecidas tanto en el sureste
de Turquía la mayoría ha muerto ahí como
en el noreste sería causado un terremoto
político tremendo en Turquía con la liga
turca en que empezó de vuelta la semana
pasada de fútbol la liga turca los
muchos aficionados están gritando a
gritos que el gobierno Turco tiene que
dimitir el gobierno sigue luchando y
esto creado tanto un caos tanto dentro
del gobierno en la política turca como
la oposición algo más de dos meses de
una campaña electoral y unas elecciones
presidenciales que se prevén claves para
el futuro de Turquía